The vertex of the parabola y equals x minus 7, squared, plus 5 is at 7,5. The
way we originally have this equation written, there is no constant term next to
y on the left hand side of the equation. Instead, outside of the portion of the
equation, where x is being modified, there's another constant term. It isn't
receiving the same kind of operations as what's inside the parentheses here with
the x. To get this in the form that we've been working with, we need to subtract
5 from both sides of the equation. That gives us an equation of y minus 5 equals
the quantity x minus 7 squared. From here, we can see that this graph should be
shifted 7 to the right, and up 5 from the parent graph. So that gives us a
vertex of 7, 5. For your viewing pleasure, here is that curve. The black one is
y equals x squared, and this green one is our new graph. Here I've written its
equation in the form that I prefer, so that we can see very easily where the
vertex is.